what we're about to make is the
boomerang plane and what you want to do
is start with a short side of the paper
up us letter size paper so we're going
to start by folding it in half the next
thing we're gonna do is find the center
of this crease that we just made and
we're just gonna make a little pinch
we're not going to make a full fold we
just put that corner to that corner and
then carefully make a pinch right there
and now we're gonna find the one-quarter
point just halfway between the center
and that corner and again we're just
gonna make a pinch we're just marking
the one-quarter point now we're gonna
use the one-quarter point and this
corner to make a crease that runs right
straight here and so we'll just use
those two landmarks to make a crease
folding that one corner over so now
we're gonna do what's called a squash
fold and to start the squash Bowl we're
going to lift this corner that we just
folded and you'll notice that you've got
two layers here we're gonna open up this
layer and that original center crease
that we made that's holding the page in
half we're gonna use that crease and
press it right down to where those
layers meet and now we're gonna take
this flap in the front and we're just
gonna fold it behind now we're gonna
start the post complicated part of this
plane is taking these corners up here
and putting them in these pockets so
let's start by moving the corner where
it's going to be it's going to be right
straight at the bottom of this triangle
see we've got a little flap that we've
created this is the pocket that I was
talking about pocket looks right there
so this corner is going into that pocket
the first move is to put it down there
about as far as it's going to go into
the pocket so let's do that I'm just
leaving about two millimeters of space
at the bottom of the pocket for that to
fit in there let's go and do the other
side at the same time so now we're going
to actually narrow this point small
enough to fit into the pocket you can
see it's much too wide so we're going to
start by moving this guy up and you have
to be able to see the pocket underneath
here I'm going to lift this for just a
second this crease that we're making
here is going to make it so it fits into
that pocket there so we're making that
just narrow enough to go in there all
the way down to the point and it's kind
of
weird move there and hold that up so you
can see that this is the edge of the
pocket and this is the new crease that
we made here and now now that it's thin
enough we're gonna put it into the
pocket so you just kind of press the
pocket open and take that corner and put
it in there we're gonna use the front of
the pocket here as a limit and we're
gonna try to get this corner here as
close to this Center crease as we can so
again the front of the pocket and try to
get that corner to touch the center
crease now we're gonna flip it over and
insert the corner into the other pocket
ready to give you an OK look at that
open up the pocket just enough insert
that flap in there and this corner just
touching the center crease again are the
limits the next move is to broaden the
wings out again we folded the wing tips
down to the center of the plane so we're
gonna move them back to the outside
there's one side done we'll flip it over
and do the other side and now we're
gonna do something real crazy we're
gonna squash that flat so we're gonna
start by picking it up and opening the
two halves of the plane and notice that
as I squash a flat you've got these two
corners here you want to keep these two
corners lined up at the center press
them together at the center and then
squash the whole thing flat now we're
going to flip it over so this folds
right straight down line up the corner
the top point with the center we're
gonna follow this crease right here fold
the plane in half and remember these
little layers that we use as limits here
they are right next to the layers here
that we're gonna use as limits for the
wing folds so leave this guy fold in
half we're gonna pull the wing over the
wing fold is going to be parallel with
the main center crease the wing folds
the wings are gonna be the same height
at the front and the tail of the plane
and the crease is going to be parallel
with this Center crease that's a really
important deal and you fold it over just
enough so you can see a little triangle
forming right here at the wing crease so
take care that these guys are parallel
we'll flip it over into the other side
so now let's do winglets and winglets
should be parallel with the wing crease
so wing crease here winglet is going to
be parallel here this
comes up that much it's about a third or
a little bit less than a third of the
whole height of the wing and you want
this crease to be parallel with this
crease moving the same direction so
let's flip it over make the other wing
match so unlike most paper airplanes
the boomerang plane the wings are going
to droop
positive dihedral helps the plane rock
back to neutral this plane the wings are
actually drooping in a negative dihedral
or anhedral fashion and that along with
where the center of gravity is helps the
boomerang plane circle back now we're
going to pull the boomerang - and the
folding is very similar to the boomerang
one first couple of moves are gonna be
very familiar if you just fold with a
boomerang plane and we're gonna fold it
in half and again we're gonna find the
center point on this crease right here
making a little pinch and now we're
gonna find again the quarter point by
measuring the halfway point between the
center point and that corner and we're
gonna use this quarter point we're
actually going to make a crease all the
way up this time and we're going to use
that as a reference point to begin the
folding sequence here so let's move that
quarter point over line everything up
perfectly make a nice sharp crease so
now we're going to fold this corner over
and we're gonna fold it over in such a
way that it just comes to rest against
this vertical crease here so we're
folding the corner over it's going to
hit there and then again you're going to
the top-left corner here and again we're
gonna run the same sequence after we get
this small triangle made we're gonna do
a squash fold just lifting that flap
opening it up and then moving the center
crease down to the center of those
layers and pressing it flat of course we
have to fold this flap behind before we
start moving those guys into pockets so
let's start by bringing this corner down
just short of the bottom of the pocket
make a crease let's flip it over make
the other side match again we're taking
this corner just short of the end of the
pocket here
[Music]
and now we're gonna narrow this corner
so it fits inside this pocket here so
we're gonna take this corner and put it
into the bottom of the pocket here so
we're narrowing it right here and now
we're gonna put it in there and again
we've got this weird bubbling
configuration and this time the front of
the pocket is still going to be where we
want to go in terms of the limit and the
back of the plane you're gonna try to
line up this edge with this edge you're
gonna try to keep these edges this one
sticking up here right here kind of
parallel with this guy here so here we
go we're bringing that down we're gonna
squash it flat using that front of the
pocket as a limit and try to keep that
edge parallel with the back edge here
now let's flip it over and now once
again we've moved the wingtips to the
inside of the plane and we want to widen
those out so we've got enough you know
airfoil there to keep the plane aloft so
we're gonna make a crease that goes from
the front of the pocket to this rear
corner here I'm just gonna move that
layer up do the same thing to the other
side let's flip it over and now that
we've got our wingtips fanned back out
we're going to squash fold the whole
body of the plane and we do that by
opening up the center crease we're going
to open this crease here and start
moving these two corners these guys here
are going to move down you can see these
guys we're gonna move them down as we
pull the layers to the outside
[Music]
so we're gonna take this corner and move
it up just so that it's right along this
edge so these guys started here and
they're going up like this and now we're
just going to reverse the direction of
these creases so that those two tabs are
sticking to the inside there's one done
so I've just started here and I'm just
tucking that under using the crease we
just made as a reference and we're going
to do the same thing for the other side
and if you feel underneath here you can
feel all the layers kind of integrate
there I'm going to take my thumbnail and
just follow that right there and that's
going to provide a reference for moving
this fold over to here this is again
we're making the landing gear here so I
have a reference we're moving this layer
over so here we go let's move the layer
over and now we're moving this fold over
now we're going to go ahead and make
wings we're gonna follow this Center
crease and fold it with all the layers
on the outside and you're gonna do an
exact measurement here it's you're going
to measure it using one of the layers on
the other side so you have to pull it
over and now you're seeing this layer
here this layer where this layer ends is
going to hit the corner of the plane's
fuselage here so you want to roll this
over and when that layer just touches
the corner underneath you have to keep
peeking and sort of doing this a little
bit by Braille you get a little bit
closer to the nose and roll that over
and hit right there so let's flip it
over the main thing is to make the other
wing match and when I fold this corner
up to make the winglet don't go past
this layer right here this is really
importantly or not to go past just go to
that or just a little bit short of that
and the winglets should be parallel
going the same direction as the main
wing crease this little crease here
making the winglet same direction as the
main wing crease let's flip it over make
the other wing let match very good okay
so the folding is now complete but it's
all about the adjusting on this guy even
more so than the boomerang one so we're
gonna start by lifting the wings up and
lay the plan on its back and now we're
going to lift up those landing gear
bolts
and now we can flip it over now we're
looking at the top of the plane now
let's lift those winglets up and now
you're gonna do a couple of things of
this plane that you would never do to
any other paper airplane because this
guy flies a lot slower and it doesn't
fly very far so step number one is to
make a weird adjustment on the nose here
we're actually going to bend the nose
down a little bit like that so that the
nose intersects the wing crease with
this weird little bend here and that's
important when the plane is upside down
believe it or not there's a little bit
of a trick right here helps keep the
nose up when the plane is upside down
the other thing we're gonna do which you
would never do any other paper airplane
is work the main center crease back and
forth flex it back and forth a bunch
there it is
the boomerang to it ready to fly we're
gonna do the bat plane which did not
start out to be the bat plane I think
this is the second plane that we're
doing that didn't start out to be
whatever I wanted it to be so the first
thing we're to do is take creases from
this corner to this corner the long
diagonal here so here we go we're gonna
fold it from this corner to this corner
it may take you a little bit of time so
I got pretty close so now we're gonna
open that up we've got this corner this
corner now we're going to do this corner
to this corner and I'm using my
thumbnail to sharpen these creases you
could use a folding tool some people
like to use a ballpoint pen cap now
we've got a big X in the page and we're
gonna make a crease that hits the center
of both of these outside edges here just
flip it over and we're gonna fold it in
half just like you would start almost
any regular paper airplane that crease
is gonna go just like that we're gonna
do what's called a waterbomb base this
crease that we just made down The Sitter
just press right straight down where all
of the creases meet just until the paper
pops like that now let the sides come in
and the top come down so the next move
is to take the right hand side and just
following this layer underneath here
we're just going to move it over you can
move this think of just moving it as far
as you can move it really moving that
layer over now we're going to take this
corner
move it to the top and now we're gonna
swivel the whole thing back to the
right-hand side that it came from so
we're gonna do the same thing with the
left side we're gonna swing this guy
over looking pretty good you can see the
shape is starting to form now we're just
gonna add a little more weight to the
nose by taking this top down to the
bottom just pulling straight down now
we're gonna fold about a third of this
distance here we're gonna fold this guy
back up how can you tell how much a
third is well the part on top of this
crease and below the crease will be the
same distance that's how you can tell
how much up there it is okay we're gonna
flip it over and we're gonna fold it in
half I'm just rotating a little bit so I
can fold it in half and again match up
these corners here these guys here match
those guys up don't worry about the
center these corners here so much don't
worry about those all right now though
there's a little bit of mojo here with
making the main wing crease and you
really want to hit it where the layers
are there's a little gap in the layers
you can kind of feel that if you just
pivot the wing over a little bit you can
start to feel where the loose part is
just let that fold happen right there
where the loose part is and flip it over
and now make the other wing match the
other wing should move down in a very
similar way we're gonna take this long
edge and put it against this edge right
here we're gonna unfold that then we're
gonna take this shorter edge up here and
move it right against the same raw edge
here so and now you've got this
crazy-looking thing here and we're gonna
pinch that corner together like that
okay let's flip it over and make the
other wing match now we're looking at
the the underside of the plane and we're
going to fold them over start at this
corner and go over about so that you're
three millimeters at the trailing edge
so it's a really thin little slice of
wing here you need to do both sides you
could hold the wings together like this
and make sure that they match and now
we're gonna use our thumb and kind of
round off the leading edge here
this is an important adjustment keeps
all of the layers on the wing go in the
same direction and kind of lock together
a little bit we've folded with heavier
paper to get you through the folding
process first time but this thing will
really flaps so much better if you use a
really lightweight paper like nine pound
onion skin or if you can find one of
those things called a phonebook you can
go back in time and find a phonebook rip
out the pages that's really nice
lightweight paper that flaps really well
so the key here is to get the leading
edges kind of lock together with a
little curve there and you'll have to
play with the leading edge droop and the
trailing edge of elevator to get the
right flapping motion
[Music]
so really the tumbling wing next which
really isn't an airplane at all in the
conventional sense it's not made to fly
so much as it is just going to fall in
an organized fashion so we're gonna take
one strip of paper here it's about two
inches wide and the length of a phone
book page around 200 millimeters by 50
millimeters if you're into the whole
metric thing and the first move we're
going to do is just fold that strip of
paper in half now we're going to fold
down about two millimeters both edges
together we're going to hold this guy
together as we fold both edges down
about two millimeters two to three
millimeters just right straight across
take your time okay so that's really the
hardest move is to fold both of those
top layers down at the same time now
we're going to unfold everything those
two top layers and the center layer so
now we're gonna put a winglet on either
end one end is going to go up and one
end is going to go down and so we're
just going to fold over about a thumb
width so that's going to be you know 20
to 22 millimeters flip it over and then
fold this up what we've really got here
is one end up and one end down you want
to make these guys have 90-degree bends
here and when we're getting ready to get
this guy to tumble this top edge is
going to point the direction of travel
so if this top edge is pointing away
from me the planes going to rotate
backwards
and move forward like that and the other
trick to getting it to fly straight is
to watch the wing droop here what do we
mean by wing droop well you've got one
long edge down one long edge up so if
it's turning to the right like we can
make a turn to the right if we just add
a lot more angle on one edge than the
other now when I throw it it's going to
veer off to the right so if it's bearing
off to the right
smooth that out so again top edge
pointed the direction of travel and
we're just gonna drop it and let it
tumble there it goes so this plane has
such a low sink rate that you can
counter that sink rate by walking
forward with a piece of cardboard with
the top of the cardboard lean slightly
back you're scooping up air and as long
as that air is moving up the same speed
the planes moving down it surfs right
there on that wave of error this is
gonna be the world record plan it's
named after my wife it's named Suzanne
short side of the paper up we're gonna
take the top of the page and put it
against the side of the page we're gonna
make two diagonal folds here standard
kind of diagonal folds we're going to
take the right-hand edge just from the
creased corner down to where this crease
meets the edge of the page and we're
gonna lay it against the diagonal fold
we're gonna take this creased corner and
bring it just to the end of this crease
right here fold the top down and now
you'll see those diagonal folds on the
other side what you want to do is line
up the diagonal folds the top layer of
the diagonal with the very bottom layer
of the diagonal on both sides and that's
how you know you're hitting the center
of the X dead center what I find to be
the easiest way to do it is to follow
the creases on this side but if you can
see them clearly on the other side and
that works for you go ahead and use it
flipped over
we're going to take this flap right here
and fold it up over those two corners
and when we do the next move to fold the
plane in half the whole thing will be
locked together so let's fold from the
top all the way down to the center of
this edge to fold the plane in half you
can flip it over and make sure the rear
corners and the nose are perfect the
center corners don't worry so much about
don't spend a lot of time trying to line
those guys up the rear corners and make
sure you're hitting the nose cleanly now
here's the pro way to do it make sure
wings a little bit wider makes the plane
a more efficient glider if you start
here and don't make the crease but see
you've got a little triangle that you
can see here made up from this raw edge
and the back of the fuselage if you keep
pulling the wing down just until that
triangle disappears that is a much
better place to make the wing crease it
makes the tail much broader gives you
much better lifting characteristics so
let's make the other wing match that
should be an easy task
does it flat keep going you've just
folded the world-record plane so clearly
it's not true that you can't fold a good
plane so let's look at a couple of
simple adjustments that are going to
work on this plane or almost any other
paper airplane so the first thing we do
we're gonna give it what's called
positive dihedral angle and what that
does when you hold on to it where all
the layers lock and just lift the
leading edge of the wings now you've got
some upward sweep there and what that
does is put the lifting surface up over
where all the way it is
so if the plane is flying along and it
gets rocked to one side just like a
pendulum the weight swings back
underneath the wings and that's called
dead-stick stability so now the plane is
going to fly along the lift is back here
it pitches the nose downward as the
planes going forward what does that do
that allows me to gain speed the plane
is being slowed now I'm pointing the
nose at the ground gaining speed which
is good but now I keep gaining speed at
9.8 meters per second per second it's
gonna crash into the ground really hard
so I bend in some elevator back here and
the air goes down the top of the wing
hits that bend gets kicked up which
pushes the tail down which lifts the
nose and voila now the nose is level
again so enough up elevator so at the
right speed the plane noses up
enough to just achieve horizontal
stability that's the whole trick with
any glider you're constantly balancing
that center of gravity center of lift
and a little bit of up elevator to get
that perfect flight and that's how you
break a world record
[Music]